NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: To take up the topic
of quantization, you
remember we're talking about
source coding in the first
part of the course, channel
coding in the
last 2/3 of the course.
Source coding, like all, is
divided into three parts.
If you have waveforms, such
as speech, you start
out with the waveform.
The typical way to encode
waveforms is you first either
sample the waveform or
you expand it in
some kind of expansion.
When you do that, you wind up
with a sequence of numbers.
You put the sequence of numbers
into a quantizer, and
the quantizer reduces that
to a discrete alphabet.
You put the discrete symbols
into the discrete encoder.
You pass it through a reliable
binary channel.
What is a reliable
binary channel?
It's a layered view of any old
channel in the world, OK?
In other words, the way that
discrete channels work these
days is that, in almost all
cases, what goes into them is
a binary stream of signals, and
what comes out of them is
a binary stream of symbols, and
the output is essentially
the same z-input.
That's the whole purpose of
how you design digital
channels, and they work
over analog media and
all sorts of things.
OK, so discrete encoders and
discrete decoders are really a
valid topic to study
in their own.
I mean, you have text and stuff
like that, which is
discrete to start with, so
there's a general topic of how
do you encode discrete things?
We've pretty much answered that
problem, at least in an
abstract sense, and the main
point there is you find the
entropy of that discrete
sequence, the entropy per
symbol, and then you find ways
of encoding that discrete
source in such a way that the
number of bits per symbol is
approximately equal
to that entropy.
We know you can't do any
better than that.
You can't do an encoding, which
is uniquely decodable,
which you can get out of with
the original symbols again,
with anything less
than the entropy.
So at least we know roughly what
the answer to that is.
We even know some classy schemes
like the Lempel-Ziv
algorithm, which will in fact
operate without even knowing
anything about what the
probabilities are.
So we sort of understand this
block here at this point.
And we could start with this
next, or we could start with
this next, and unlike the
electrician here, we're going
to move in sequence and look at
this next and this third.
There's another reason
for that.
When we get into this question,
we will be talking
about what do you do
with waveforms?
How do you deal with
waveforms?
It's what you've been studying
probably since the sixth
grade, and you're all
familiar with it.
You do integration and
things like that.
You know how to work
with functions.
What we're going to do with
functions in this course is a
little bit different than
what you're used to.
It's quite a bit different than
what you learned in your
Signals and Systems course, and
you'll find out why as we
move along.
But we have to understand this
business of how to deal with
waveforms, both in terms of this
block, which is the final
block we'll study in source
coding, and also in terms of
how to deal with channels
because in real channels,
generally what you transmit
is a waveform.
What the noise does to you is to
add a waveform or, in some
sense, multiply what you put
in by something else.
And all of that is
waveform stuff.
And all of information theory
and all of digital
communication is based
on thinking bits.
So somehow or other, we have to
become very facile in going
from waveforms to bits.
Now I've been around the
professional communities of
both communication and
information theory for
a long, long time.
There is one fundamental problem
that gives everyone
problems because information
theory texts do not deal with
it and communication texts
do not deal with it.
And that problem is how do you
go from one to the other,
which seems like it ought
to be an easy thing.
It's not as easy as it looks,
and therefore, we're going to
spent quite a bit
of time on that.
In fact, I passed out lectures
6 and 7 today, which in
previous years I've done in two
separate lectures because
quantization is a problem
that looks important.
We'll see that it's not quite
as important as it looks.
And I guess the other thing is,
I mean, at different times
you have to teach different
things or you get stale on it.
And I've just finished writing
some fairly nice notes, I
think, on this question of how
do you go from waveforms to
numbers and how do you go from
numbers to waveforms.
And I want to spend a little
more time on that this year
than I did last year.
I want to spend, therefore,
a little less time on
quantization, so that next time,
we will briefly review
what we've done today on
quantization, but we will
essentially just compress
those two
lectures all into one.
In dealing with waveforms,
we're going to learn some
interesting and kind
of cool things.
Like for those of you who
really don't -- are not
interested in mathematics, you
know that people study things
like the theory of real
variables and functional
analysis and all of these neat
things, which are very, in a
sense, advanced mathematics.
They're all based on measure
theory, and you're going to
find out a little bit about
measure theory here.
Not an awful lot, but just
enough to know why one has to
deal with those questions
because the major results in
dealing with waveforms and
samples really can't be stated
in any other form than
in a somewhat
measure-theoretic form.
So we're going to find just
enough about that so we can
understand what those
issues are about.
So that's why next time we're
going to start dealing with
the waveform issues.
OK, so today, we're dealing with
these quantizer issues
and how do you take a sequence
of numbers, turn them into a
sequence of symbols
at the other end?
How do you take a sequence
of symbols, turn
them back into numbers?
So when you convert real numbers
to binary strings, you
need a mapping from the
set of real numbers
to a discrete alphabet.
And we're typically going to
have a mapping from the set of
real numbers into a finite
discrete alphabet.
Now what's the first obvious
thing that you notice when you
have a mapping that goes from an
infinite set of things into
a finite set of things?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
PROFESSOR: Not really.
It's a much simpler
idea than that.
How are you going to get back?
I mean, usually when you map
something into something else,
you would like to
get back again.
When you map an infinite set
into a finite set, how are you
going to get back?
AUDIENCE: You're not.
PROFESSOR: You're not.
Good!
There's not any way in hell
that you're ever going
to get back, OK?
So, in other words, what
you've done here is to
deliberately introduce some
distortion into the picture.
You've introduced distortion
because you have no choice.
If you want to turn numbers into
bits, you can't get back
to the exact numbers again.
So you can only get back to some
approximation of what the
numbers are.
But anyway, this process of
doing this is called scalar
quantization, if we're mapping
from the set of real numbers
to a discrete alphabet.
If instead you want to convert
real n-tuples into sequences
of discrete symbols, in other
words, into a finite alphabet,
you call that vector
quantization because you can
view n real numbers, a sequence
of n real numbers as
a vector within coordinates
and within components.
And I'm not doing anything
fancy with vectors here.
You just look at an n-tuple
of numbers as a vector.
OK, so scalar quantization is
going to encode each term of
the source sequence
separately.
And vector quantization is first
going to segment this
sequence of numbers into blocks
of n numbers each, and
then it's going to find a way
of encoding those n-blocks
into discrete symbols.
Does this sound a little bit
like what we've already done
in dealing with discrete
sources?
Yeah, it's exactly
the same thing.
I mean, we started out by
mapping individual symbols
into bit sequences, and then we
said, gee, we can also map
n-blocks of those symbols into
bits, and we said, gee, this
is the same problem again.
There's nothing different,
nothing new.
And it's the same thing here
almost except here the
properties of the real numbers
are important.
Why are the properties of the
real numbers important?
Why can't we just look
at this as symbols?
Well, because, since we can't
do this mapping in an
invertable way, you have to deal
with the fact that you
have distortion here.
There's no other way
to think about it.
There is distortion.
You might as well face it.
If you try to cover it
up, it just comes
up to kick you later.
So we face it right in the
beginning, and that's why we
deal with these things
as numbers.
So let's look at a simple
example of what a scalar
quantizer is going to do.
Basically, what we have to do
is to map the line R, mainly
the set of real numbers, into
M different regions, which
we'll call R1 up to R sub M.
And in this picture here,
here's R1, here's R2, here's R3,
here's R4, R5 and R6, and
that's all the regions
we have.
You'll notice one of the things
that that does is it
takes an enormous set of
numbers, namely all these
numbers less than this,
and match them all
into the same symbol.
So you might wind up with a
fair amount of distortion
there, no matter how you
measure distortion.
All these outliers here all
get mapped into a6, and
everything in the middle gets
mapped somehow into these
intermediate values.
But every source value now in
the region R sub j, we're
going to map into a
representation point a sub j.
So everything in R1 is going
to be mapped into a1.
Everything in R2 is going
to get mapped
into a2 and so forth.
Is this a general way to map
R into a set of M symbols?
Is there anything else I ought
to be thinking about?
Well, here, these regions here
have a very special property.
Namely, each region
is an interval.
And we might say to ourselves,
well, maybe we shouldn't map
points into intervals.
But aside from the fact that
we've chosen intervals here,
this is a perfectly general
way to represent a mapping
from the real numbers into
a discrete set of things.
Namely, when you're doing a
mapping from the real numbers
into a discrete set of things,
there's some set of real
numbers that get mapped
into a1, and that by
definition is called R1.
There's some set of numbers
which get mapped into a2.
That by definition is called
R2 and so forth.
So aside from the fact that
these intervals with these
regions in this picture happen
to be intervals, this is a
perfectly general mapping from
R into a discrete alphabet.
So since I've decided I'm
going to look at scalar
quantizers first, this is a
completely general view of
what a scalar quantizer is.
You tell me how many
quantization regions you want,
namely how big the alphabet is
that you're mapping things
into, and then your only problem
is how do you choose
these regions and how
do you choose the
representation points?
OK, one new thing here: Before,
we said when you have
a set of symbols a1 up to
a6, it doesn't matter
what you call them.
They're just six symbols.
Here it makes a difference what
you call them because
here they are representing
real numbers and they are
representing real numbers
because when you map some real
number on the real line into one
of these letters here, the
distortion is u minus a sub j.
If you're mapping u into a sub
j, then you get a distortion,
which is this difference here.
I haven't said yet what I am
interested in as far as
distortion is concerned.
Am I interested in squared
distortion, cubed distortion,
absolute magnitude
of distortion?
I haven't answered that
question yet.
But there is a distortion here,
and somehow that has to
be important.
We have to come to grips with
what we call a distortion and
somehow how big that distortion
is going to be.
So our problem here is somehow
to trade off between
distortion and number
of points.
As we make the number of
points bigger, we can
presumably make the distortion
smaller in some sense,
although the distortion is
always going to be very big
from these really big negative
numbers and from really big
positive numbers.
But aside from that, we just
have a problem of how do you
choose the regions?
How do you choose the points?
OK, I've sort of forgotten
about the problem that we
started with.
And the problem that we started
with was to have a
source where the source was
a sequence of numbers.
And when we're talking about
sources, we're talking about
something stochastic.
We need a probability measure
on these real numbers that
we're encoding.
If we knew what they were, there
wouldn't be any need to
encode them.
I mean, if we knew and the
receiver knew, there would be
no need to encode them.
The receiver would just print
out what they were or store
them or do whatever
the receiver
wants to do with them.
OK, so we're going to view the
source value u with the sample
value of some random variable
capital U. And more generally,
since we have a sequence, we're
going to consider a
source sequence to be U1, U2, U3
and so forth, or you could
consider it a bi-infinite
sequence, starting at U minus
infinity and working
its way up forever.
And then we're going to have
some sort of model,
statistical model, for this
sequence of random variables.
Our typical model for these is
to assume that we have a
memoryless source.
In other words, U1, U2, U3 are
independent, identically
distributed, random variables.
That's the model we'll use until
we get smarter and start
to think of something else.
OK, so now each of these source
values we're going to
map into some representation
point a sub j.
That's what defines
the quantizer.
And now since a sub j is a
sample value of a random
variable U, a sub j is going to
be a sample value of some
random variable V. OK, in other
words, the probabilities
of these different sample
values is going to be
determined by the set of U's
that math into that a sub j.
So we have a source sequence
U1, U2, blah, blah, blah.
We have a representation
sequence V1, V2, blah, blah,
blah, which is defined by if U
sub k is in R sub j, then Vk
is equal to a sub j.
Point of confusion here: It's
not confusing now, but it will
be confusing at some
point to you.
When you're talking about
sources, you really need two
indices that you're talking
about all the time.
OK, one of them is
how to represent
different elements in time.
Here we're using k as a way of
keeping track of what element
in time we're talking about.
We're also talking about a
discrete alphabet, which has a
certain number of elements in
it, which is completely
independent of time.
Namely, we've just described
the quantizer as something
which maps real numbers
into sample values.
It has nothing to do
with time at all.
We're going to use that same
thing again and again and
again, and we're using
the subscript j
to talk about that.
When you write out problem
solutions, you are going to
find that it's incredibly
difficult sometimes to write
sentences which distinguish
about whether you're talking
about one element out of an
alphabet or one element out of
a time sequence.
And everybody has that trouble,
and you read most of
the literature in information
theory or communication
theory, and you can't sort out
most of the time what people
are talking about because
they're doing that.
I recommend to you using an
element and an alphabet to
talk about this sort of thing,
what a sub j is or an element
and a time sequence to
keep track of things
at different times.
It's a nice way of keeping
them straight.
OK, so anyway, for a scalar
quantizer, we're going to be
able to just look at a single
random variable U, which is a
continuous-valued random
variable, which takes values
anywhere on the real line and
maps it into a single element
in this discrete alphabet, which
is the set a1 up to a6
that we were talking
about here.
So a scalar quantizer then is
just a map of this form, OK?
So the only thing we need for a
scalar quantizer, we can now
forget about time and talk about
how do you choose the
regions, how do you choose the
representation points?
OK, and there's a nice
algorithm there.
Again, one of these things,
which if you were the first
person to think about it, easy
way to become famous.
You might not stay famous, but
you can get famous initially.
Anyway, we're almost always
interested in the mean squared
error or the mean squared
distortion, MSD or MSE, which
is the expected value of U minus
V. U is this real-valued
random variable.
V is the discrete random
variable into which it maps.
We have the distortion between
U and V, which is U minus V.
We now have the expected value
of that squared distortion.
Why is everybody interested in
squared distortion instead of
magnitude distortion
or something else?
In many engineering problems,
you should be more interested
in magnitude distortion.
Sometimes you're much more
interested in fourth-moment
distortion or some other
strange thing.
Why do we always use mean
squared distortion?
And why do we use mean-squared
everything throughout almost
everything we do in
communication?
I'll tell you the reason now.
We'll come back and talk about
it more a number of times.
It's because this quantization
problem that we're talking
about is almost always a
subproblem of this problem,
where you're dealing with
waveforms, where you take the
waveform and you sample the
waveform, where you take the
waveform, and you turn the
waveform into some expansion.
When you find the mean-squared
distortion in a quantizer, it
turns out that that maps in
a beautiful way into the
mean-squared distortion
between waveforms.
If you deal with magnitudes or
with anything else in the
world, all of that beauty
goes away, OK?
In other words, whenever you
want to go from waveforms to
numbers, the one thing which
remains invariant, which
remains nice all the way
through, is this mean-square
distortion, mean-square
value, OK?
In other words, if you want
to layer this problem into
looking at this problem
separately from looking at
this problem, almost the only
way you can do it that makes
sense is to worry about mean
square distortion rather than
some other kind of distortion.
So even though as engineers
we might be interested in
something else, we almost always
stick to that because
that's the thing that we can
deal with most nicely.
I mean, as engineers, we're like
the drunk who dropped his
wallet on a dark street, and
he's searching for it, and
somebody comes along.
And here he is underneath a
beautiful light where he can
see everything.
Somebody asks him what he's
looking for you, and he says
he's looking for his wallet.
The guy looks down and says,
well, there's no wallet there.
The drunk says I know.
I dropped it over there, but
it's dark over there.
So we use mean square
distortion in
exactly the same sense.
It isn't necessarily the problem
we're interested in,
but it's a problem where we
can see things clearly.
So given that we're interested
in the mean square distortion
of a scalar quantizer, an
interesting analytical problem
that we can play with is for a
given probability density on
this real random variable, and
we're assuming we have a
probability density and a given
alphabet size M, the
problem is how do you choose
these regions and how do you
choose these representation
points in such a way as to
minimize the mean square
error, OK?
So, in other words, we've taken
a big sort of messy
amorphous engineering problem,
and we said, OK, we're going
to deal with mean square error,
and OK, we're going to
deal with scalar quantizers, and
OK, we're going to fix a
number of quantization levels,
so we've made all those
choices to start with.
We still have this interesting
problem of how do you choose
the right regions?
How do you choose the
right sample points?
And that turns out to
be a simple problem.
I wouldn't talk about
if it wasn't simple.
And we'll break it into
subproblems, and the
subproblems are really simple.
The first subproblem is if I
tell you what representation
points I want to use, namely,
in this picture here, I say
OK, I want to use these
representation points.
And then I ask you, how are
you going to choose the
regions in an optimal way to
minimize mean square error?
Well, you think about that for
awhile, and you think about it
in a number of ways.
When you think about it in just
the right way, the answer
becomes obvious.
And the answer is, let me not
think about the regions here,
but let me think about a
particular value that comes
out of the source.
Let me think, how should I
construct a rule for how to
take outputs from this
source and map them
into some number here.
So if I get some output from
the source u, I say, OK,
what's the distortion
between u and a1?
It's u minus a1.
And the magnitude of that is the
magnitude of u minus a1.
The square of it is the square
of u minus a1, and then say,
OK, let me compare that
with u minus a2.
Let me compare it with u
minus a3 and so forth.
Let me choose the smallest
of those things.
What's the smallest stuff
for any given u?
Suppose I have a u which
happens to be
right there, for example.
What's the closest
representation point?
Well, a3 is obviously
closer than a2.
And in fact for any point in
here, which is closer to a3
than it is to a2, we're
going to choose a3.
Now what's the set of points
which are closer to a3 than
they are to a2?
Well, you put a line here right
between a2 and a3, OK?
When you put that line right
between a2 and a3, everything
on this side is closer to a3 and
everything on this side is
closer to a2.
So the answer is,
in fact, simple,
once you see the answer.
And the answer is, given these
points, we simply construct
bisectors between them, namely,
bisectors with --
halfway between a1 and
a2, we call that b1.
Halfway between a2 and a3, we
call that b2, and those are
the separators between
the regions, OK?
In other words, what we wind
up doing is we define the
region R sub j, the set of
things which get mapped into a
sub j as the region which is
bounded by bj minus 1 is the
average of aj and aj minus 1,
and bj is the average of aj
and aj plus 1, where I've
already ordered the points a
sub j going from left
to right, OK?
And that also tells us that the
minimum mean square error
regions have got to
be intervals.
There is no reason at all to
ever pick regions which are
not intervals because, as soon
as you start to solve this
problem for any given set of
representation points, you
wind up with intervals.
So if you ever think of using
things that are not intervals
for this mean square error
problem, then as soon as you
look at this, you say, well,
aha, that can't be the best
thing to do.
I will make my regions
intervals.
I will therefore simplify the
whole problem, and I'll also
improve it.
And when you can both simplify
things and improve them at the
same time, it usually is worth
doing it unless you're dealing
with standards bodies or
something, and then
all bets are off.
OK, so this one part of
the problem is easy.
If we know what the
representation points are, we
can solve the problem.
OK, we have a second problem,
which is just
the opposite problem.
Suppose then that somebody gives
you the interval regions
and asks you, OK, if I give you
these interval regions,
how are you going to choose the
representation points to
minimize the mean
square error?
And analytically that's harder,
but conceptually, it's
just about as easy.
And let's look at it and see
if we can understand it.
Somebody gives us this region
here, R sub 2, and says, OK,
where should we put
the point a sub 2?
Well, anybody have any
clues as to where
you want to put it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: At the midpoint?
PROFESSOR: At the midpoint.
It sounds like a reasonable
thing, but
it's not quite right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
PROFESSOR: It depends on the
probability density, yes.
If you have a probability
density, which is highly
weighted over on -- let's see,
was I talking about R2 or R3?
Well, it doesn't make
any difference.
We'll talk about R2.
If I have a probability density,
which looks like
this, then I want a2 to be
closer to the left-hand side
than to the right-hand side.
I want it to be a little bit
weighted towards here because
that's more important
in choosing
the mean square error.
OK, if you didn't have any of
this stuff, and I said how do
I choose this to minimize the
mean square error, what's your
answer then?
If I just have one region and
I want to minimize the mean
square error, what do you do?
Anybody who doesn't know should
go back and study
elementary probability theory
because this is almost day one
of elementary probability theory
when you start to study
what random variables
are all about.
And the next thing you start
to look at is things like
variance and second moment.
And what I'm asking you here
is, how do you choose a2 in
order to minimize the second
moment of U, whatever it is in
here, minus a2?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I want to take
the expectation of U
over the region R2.
In other words, to say it more
technically, I want to take
the expectation of the
conditional random variable U,
conditional on being
in R2, OK?
And all of you could figure that
out yourselves, if you
sat down quietly and thought
about it for five minutes.
If you got frightened about it
and started looking it up in a
book or something, it
would take you about
two hours to do it.
But if you just asked
yourselves, how do I do it?
You'll come up with the right
answer very, very soon, OK?
So subproblem 2 says let's
look at the conditional
density of U in this
region R sub j.
I'll call the conditional
density -- well, the
conditional density, given that
you're in this region,
is, in fact, the real density
divided by the probability of
being in that interval, OK?
So we'll call that the
conditional density.
And I'll let U of j be the
random variable, which has
this density.
In other words, this isn't
a random variable on the
probability space that we
started to deal with it.
It's sort of a phony
random variable.
But, in fact, it's the
intuitive thing that
you think of, OK?
In other words, if this is
exactly what you were thinking
of, you probably wouldn't have
called this a separate random
variable, OK?
So this is a random variable
with this density.
The expected value of U of j
minus a of j quantity squared,
as you all know, is sigma
squared of U of j plus the
expected value a U of j minus a
sub j quantity squared, OK?
How do you minimize this?
Well, you're stuck with this.
This term, you minimize it by
making a sub j equal to the
expected value of
U of j, which is
exactly what you said.
Namely, you set a of j to be the
conditional mean of U of j
conditional on being
in the center.
It's harder to say
mathematically than
it is to see it.
But, in fact, the intuitive
idea is exactly right.
Namely, you condition your
random variable on being in
that interval, and then what you
want to do is choose the
mean within that interval, which
is exactly the sort of
thing we were thinking
about here.
When I drew this curve here, if
I scale it, this, in fact,
is the density of
u conditional on
being in R sub j.
And now all I'm trying to do
is choose the point here,
which happens to be
the mean which
minimizes this second moment.
The second moment, in fact,
is this mean square error.
So, bingo!
That's the second problem.
Well, how do you put the
two problems together?
Well, you can put it together
in two ways.
One of them is to say, OK, well
then, clearly an optimal
scalar quantizer has to
satisfy both of these
conditions.
Namely, the endpoints of the
regions have to be the
midpoints of the representation
points, and the
representation points have to
be the conditional means of
the points within a region
that you start with.
And then you say, OK, how
do I solve that problem?
Well, if you're a computer
scientist, and sometimes it's
good to be a computer scientist,
you say, well, I
don't know how to solve the
problem, but generating an
algorithm to solve the problem
is almost trivial.
I start out with some
arbitrary set of
representation points.
That should be a capital M
because that's the number of
points I'm allowed to use.
Then the next step in the
algorithm is I choose these
separation points to be b sub j
is the midpoint between the
a's for each of these values.
Then as soon as I get these
midpoints, I have a set of
intervals, and my next step is
to say set a sub j is equal to
the expected value of this
conditional random variable U
of j where R sub j is now this
new interval for 1 less than
or equal to j less than
or equal to M minus 1.
This means it's open
on the left side.
This means it's closed on the
right side, and since it's a
probability density, it doesn't
make any difference
what it is.
I just wanted to give you an
explicit rule for what to do
with probability zero when you
happen to wind up on that
special point.
OK, and then you iterate on
2 and 3 until you get a
negligible improvement.
And then you ask, of course,
well, if I got a negligible
improvement this time, maybe
I'll get a bigger
improvement next time.
And that, of course, is true.
And you then say, well, it's
possible that after I can't
get any improvement anymore,
I still don't
have the optimal solution.
And that, of course,
is true also.
But at least you have an
algorithm which makes sense
and which, each time you try
it, you do a little better
than you did before.
Now, this mean square error for
any choice of regions and
any choice of representation
points is going to be
nonnegative because
it's an expected
value of squared terms.
The algorithm is nonincreasing
with iterations.
In other words, the algorithm
is going down all the time.
So you have zero down here.
You have an algorithm which is
marching you down toward zero.
It's not going to get to zero,
but it has to reach a minimum.
That's a major theorem in
analysis, but you don't need
any major theorems in analysis
to see this.
You have a set of numbers, which
are decreasing all the
time, and they're bounded
underneath.
After awhile, you have to get
to some point, and you don't
go any further.
So it has a limit.
So that's nice.
So you have an algorithm
which has to converge.
It can't keep on going.
Well, it can keep on going
forever, but it keeps going on
forever with smaller and
smaller improvements.
So eventually, you might as well
stop because you're not
getting anywhere.
OK, well, those conditions
that we stated, the way a
mathematician would say this, is
these Lloyd-Max conditions
are necessary but not
sufficient, OK?
In other words, any solution
to this problem that we're
looking at has to have
the property that the
representation points are the
conditional means of the
intervals and the interval
boundaries are the midpoints
between the representation
points.
But that isn't necessarily
enough.
Here's a simple example of
where it's not enough.
Suppose you have a probability
density, which is running
along almost zero, jumps up to
a big value, almost zero,
jumps up to a big value, jumps
up to a big value.
This intentionally is wider than
this and wider than this.
In other words, there's a lot
more probability over here
than there is here
or there is here.
And you're unlucky, and you
start out somehow with points
like a1 and a2, and you start
out with regions like R1 --
well, yeah, you want to start
out with points, a1 and a2.
So you start out with a point
a1, which is way over here,
and a point a2, which is
not too far over here.
And your algorithm then says
pick the midpoint b1.
Here the algorithm is
particularly simple because,
since we're only using two
regions, all you need is one
separator point.
So we wind up with b1 here,
which is halfway
between a1 and a2.
a1 happens to be right in the
middle of that big interval
there, and there's hardly
anything else here.
So a1 just stays there as the
conditional mean, given that
you're on this side.
And a2 stays as the conditional
mean, given that
you're over here, which means
that a2 is a little closer
this big region than it is
to this region, but a2 is
perfectly happy there.
And we go back and
we iterate again.
And we haven't changed b1, we
haven't changed a1, we haven't
changed a2, and therefore, the
algorithm sticks there.
Well, that's not surprising.
I mean, you know that there are
many problems where you
try to minimize things by
differentiating or all the
different tricks you have for
minimizing things, and you
very often find local minima.
People call algorithms like this
hill-climbing algorithms.
They should call them
valley-finding algorithms
because we're sitting
at someplace.
We try to find a better place.
So we wind up moving
down into the
valley further and further.
Of course, if it's a real
geographical area, you finally
wind up at the river.
You then move down the river,
you wind up in the
ocean and all that.
But let's forgot about that.
Let's just assume that there
aren't rivers or anything.
That we just have some arbitrary
geographical area.
We wind up in the bottom of a
valley, and we say, OK, are we
at the minimum or not?
Well, with hill climbing, you
can take a pair of binoculars,
and you look around to see if
there's any higher peak
someplace else.
With valley seeking,
you can't do that.
We're sitting there at the
bottom of the valley, and we
have no idea whether there's a
better valley somewhere else
or not, OK?
So that's the trouble with
hill-climbing algorithms or
valley-seeking algorithms.
And that's exactly what
this algorithm does.
This is called the Lloyd-Max
algorithm because a guy by the
name of Lloyd at Bell Labs
discovered it, I think in '57.
A guy by the name of Joel
Max discovered it again.
He was at MIT in 1960, and
because all the information
theorists around were at MIT at
that time, they called it
the Max algorithm
for many years.
And then somebody discovered
that Lloyd had done it three
years earlier.
Lloyd never even published it.
So it became the Lloyd-Max
algorithm.
And now there's somebody else
who did it even earlier, I
think, so we should probably
take Max's name off it.
But anyway, sometime when I
revise the notes, I will give
the whole story of that.
But I hope you see that
this algorithm
is no big deal anyway.
It was just people fortunately
looking at the question at the
right time before too many other
people had looked at it.
And Max unfortunately
looked at it.
He was in a valley.
He didn't see all the other
people had looked at it.
But he became famous.
He had his moment of time and
then sunk gradually into
oblivion except when once
in awhile we call it the
Lloyd-Max algorithm.
Most people call it the Lloyd
algorithm, though, and I
really should also.
OK, vector quantization:
We talked about vector
quantization a little bit.
It's the idea of segmenting the
source outputs before you
try to do the encoding.
So we ask is scalar quantization
going to be the
right approach?
To answer that question, we want
to look at quantizing two
sample values jointly and
drawing pictures.
Incidentally, what's the
simplest way of quantizing
that you can think of?
And what do people who do simple
things call quantizers?
Ever hear of an
analog-to-digital converter?
That's what a quantizer is.
And an analog-to-digital
converter, the way that
everybody does it, is scalar.
So that says that either the
people who implement things
are very stupid, or there's
something pretty good about
scalar quantization.
But anyway, since this is a
course trying to find better
ways of doing things, we ought
to investigate whether it is
better to use vector
quantizers and
what they result in.
OK, well, the first thing that
we can do is look at
quantizing two samples.
In other words, when you want
to generalize a problem to
vectors, I find it better to
generalize it to two vectors
first and see what
goes on there.
And one possible approach is to
use a rectangular grid of
quantization regions.
And as I'll show you in the
next slide, that really is
just a camouflaged scalar
quantizer again.
So you have a two-dimensional
region corresponding to two
real samples.
So you've got two real
numbers, U1 and U2.
You're trying to map them into
a finite set of sample values
of representation points.
Since you're going to be
interested in the distortion
between U1 and U2, between the
vector U1, U2, and your
representation vector, a1,
a2, these points, these
representation points, are going
to be two-dimensional
points also.
So if you start out by saying
let's put these points on a
rectangular grid, well, we can
then look at it, and we say,
well, given the points, how
do we choose the regions?
You see, it's exactly
the same problem
that you solved before.
If I give you the points and
then I ask you, well, if we
get a vector U1, U2 that's
there, what do we map it to?
Well, we map it to the closest
thing, which means if we want
to find these regions, we set
up these perpendicular
bisectors halfway between the
representation points.
So all of this is looking very
rectangular now because we
started out with these
points rectangular.
These lines are rectangular, and
now I say, well, is this
really any different from
a scalar quantizer?
And, of course, it isn't because
for this particular
vector quantizer, I can first
ask the question, OK, here's
U1, which is something
in this direction.
How do I find regions
for that?
Well, for U1, I just establish
these regions here.
And then I say, OK, let's
look at U2 next.
And then I look at things in
this direction, and I wind up
in saying, OK, that's all
there is to the problem.
I have a scalar quantizer
again.
Everything that I said
before works.
Now if you're a theoretician,
you go one step further, and
you say, what this tells me is
that vector quantizers cannot
be any worse than scalar
quantizers.
Because, in fact, a vector
quantizer has a -- or at least
a vector quantizer in two
dimensions -- has a scalar
quantizer --
has two scalar quantizers
as a special case.
And therefore, the amount of
square distortion that I wind
up with in the vector case,
I can always get that --
whatever I can do with the
scalar quantizer, I can do
just as well with a vector
quantizer by choosing it, in
fact, to be rectangular
like this.
And you can also get some
intuitive ideas that if
instead of having IID random
variables, if U1 and U2 are
very heavily correlated somehow
so that they're very
close together, I mean, you
sort of get an engineering
view of what you want to do.
You want to take this
rectangular picture here.
You want to skew it
around that way.
And you want to have lots of
points going this way and not
too many points going this way
because almost everything is
going this way, and
there's not much
going on in that direction.
So you got some pictures
of what you want to do.
These regions here, a little bit
of terminology, are called
Voronoi regions.
Anytime you start out with a
set of points and you put
perpendicular bisectors in
between those points, halfway
between the points, you call the
regions that you wind up
with Voronoi regions.
So, in fact, part of this
Lloyd-Max algorithm,
generalized at two dimensions,
says given any set of points,
the regions ought to be the
Voronoi regions for them.
So that's that first subproblem
generalized at two
dimensions.
And if you have an arbitrary
set of points, the Voronoi
regions look sort of
like this, OK?
And I've only drawn it for the
center point because, well,
there aren't enough points to
do anything more than that.
So anything in this region gets
mapped into this point.
Anything in this semi-infinite
region gets mapped into this
point and so forth.
So even in two dimensions,
this part of the
algorithm is simple.
When you start out with the
regions, with almost the same
argument that we used before,
you can see that the mean
square error is going to be
minimized by using conditional
means for the representation
points.
I mean, that's done in
detail in the notes.
It's just algebra to do that.
It's sort of intuitive that
the same thing ought to
happen, and in fact, it does.
So you can still find
a local minimum by
this Lloyd-Max algorithm.
If you're unhappy with the
fact that the Lloyd-Max
algorithm doesn't always work
in one dimension, be content
with the fact that it's far
worse in two dimensions, and
it gets worse and worse as you
go to higher numbers of
dimensions.
So it is a local minimum,
but not
necessarily the best thing.
OK, well, about that time, and
let's go forward for maybe 10
years from 1957 and '60 when
people were inventing the
Lloyd-Max algorithm and where
they thought that quantization
was a really neat academic
problem, and many people were
writing theses on it and having
lots of fun with it.
And then eventually, they
started to realize that when
you try to solve that problem
and find the minimum, it
really is just a very
ugly problem.
At least it looks like a very
ugly problem with everything
that anybody knows after
having worked on it
for a very long time.
So not many people work
on this anymore.
So we stop and say, well, we
really don't want to go too
far on this because it's ugly.
But then we stop and think.
I mean, anytime you get stuck
on a problem, you ought to
stop and ask, well, am
I really looking
at the right problem?
Now why am I or why am I not
looking at the right problem?
And remember where
we started off.
We started off with this kind
of layered solution, which
said we were going to quantize
these things into a finite
alphabet and then
we were going to
discrete code them, OK?
And here what we've been
doing for awhile,
and none of you objected.
Of course, it's hard to object
at 9:30 in the morning.
You just listen and you -- but
you should have objected.
You should have said why in hell
am I choosing the number
of quantization levels
to minimize over?
What should I be minimizing
over?
I should be trying to find the
minimum mean square error
conditional on the entropy
of this output alphabet.
Because the entropy of the
output alphabet is what
determines what I can accomplish
by discrete coding.
That's a slightly phony problem
because I'm insisting,
now at least to start with, that
the quantizer is a scalar
quantizer, and by using coding
here, I'm allowing memory in
the coding process.
But it's not that phony
because, in fact, this
quantization job is a real
mess, and this job
is very, very easy.
And, in fact, when you think
about it a little bit, you
say, OK, how do people really
do this if they're trying to
implement things?
And how would you go about
implementing something like
this entire problem that
we're talking about?
What would you do if you
had to implement it?
Well, you're probably afraid to
say it, but you would use
digital signal processing,
wouldn't you?
I mean, the first thing you
would try to do is to get rid
of all these analog values, and
you would try to turn them
into discrete values, so that
you would really, after you
somehow find this sequence of
numbers here, you would go
through a quantizer and quantize
these numbers very,
very finely.
You would think of them as real
numbers, and then you
would do some kind of discrete
coding, and you would wind up
with something.
And then you would say, ah, I
have quantized these things
very, very finely.
And we'll see that when you
quantize it very, very finely,
what you're going to wind up
with, which is almost optimal,
is a uniform scalar quantizer,
which is just what a
garden-variety analog-to-digital
converter
does for you, OK?
But then you say, aha!
What I can't do at that moment,
I don't have enough
bits to represent what this very
fine quantizer has done.
So then I think of this
quantization as real numbers.
I go through the same process
again, and I think of then
quantizing the real numbers
to the number of
bits I really want.
Anybody catch what
I just said?
I'm saying you do this
in two steps.
The first step is a very fine
quantization, strictly for
implementation purposes and
for no other reason.
And at that point, you
have bits to process.
You do digital-signal
processing, but you think of
those bits as representing
numbers, OK?
In other words, as far as your
thoughts are concerned, you're
not dealing with the
quantization errors that
occurred here at all.
You're just thinking
of real numbers.
And at that point, you try to
design conceptually what it is
you want to do in this
process of quantizing
and discrete coding.
And you then go back to looking
at these things as
numbers again, and you quantize
them again, and you
discrete encode them again in
whatever way makes sense.
So you do one thing strictly for
implementation purposes.
You do the other thing for
conceptual purposes.
Then you put them together into
something that works.
And that's the way engineers
operate all the time, I think.
At least they did when I was
more active doing real
engineering.
OK, so that's that.
But anyway, it says finding a
minimum mean square error
quantizer for fixed M isn't the
right problem that we're
interested in.
If you're going to have
quantization followed by
discrete coding, the quantizer
should minimize mean square
error for fixed representation
point entropy.
In other words, I'd
want to find these
representation points.
It's important what the
numerical values of the
representation points are for
mean square error, but I'm not
interested in how many
of them I have.
What I'm interested in is
the entropy of them.
OK, so the quantizer should
minimize mean square error for
a fixed representation
point entropy.
I would like some algorithm,
which goes through and changes
my representation points,
including perhaps changing the
number of representation
points as a
way of reducing entropy.
OK, sometimes you can get more
representation points by
having them out where there's
virtually no probability, and
therefore they don't happen very
often, but when they do
happen, they sure save
you an awful lot
of mean square error.
So you can wind up with things
using many, many more
quantization points than you
would think you would want
because that's the optimal
thing to do.
OK, when you're given the
regions, if we try to say what
happens to the Lloyd-Max
algorithm then, the
representation points
should still be
the conditional means.
Why?
Anybody figure out why we want
to solve the problem that way?
If I've already figured out what
the region should the --
well, before, when I told you
what the regions were, you
told me that you wanted to make
the representation points
the conditional means.
Now if I make the representation
points
something other than the
conditional means, what's
going to happen to
the entropy?
The entropy stays the same.
The entropy has nothing
to do with what
you call these symbols.
I can move where they are, but
they still have the same
probability because they still
occur whenever you wind up in
that region.
And therefore, the entropy
doesn't change, and therefore,
the same rule holds.
But now the peculiar thing is
you don't want to make the
representation regions Voronoi
regions anymore.
In other words, sometimes you
want to make a region much
closer to one point than
to the other point.
And why do you want
to do that?
Because you'd like to make these
probabilities of the
points as unequal as you can
because you're trying to
reduce entropy.
And you can reduce entropy by
making things have different
probabilities.
OK, so that's where we
wind up with that.
I would like to say there's
a nice algorithm
to solve this problem.
There isn't.
It's an incredibly
ugly problem.
You might think it makes sense
to use a Lagrange multiplier
approach and try to minimize
some linear combination of
entropy and mean square error.
I've never been able
to make it work.
So anyway, let's go on.
When we want to look at a
high-rate quantizer, which is
what we very often want, you
can do a very simple
approximation.
And the simple approximation
makes the problem much easier,
and it gives you an
added benefit.
There's something called
differential entropy.
And differential entropy is the
same as ordinary entropy,
except instead of dealing with
probabilities, it deals with
probability densities.
And you look at this, and you
say, well, that's virtually
the same thing, and it looks
like the same thing.
And to most physicists, most
physicists look at something
like this, and physicists who
are into statistical mechanics
say, oh, of course that's
the same thing.
There's no fundamental
difference between a
differential entropy
and a real entropy.
And you say, well, but
they're all these
scaling issues there.
And they say, blah, that's
not important.
And they're right, because once
you understand it, it's
not important.
But let's look and see what the
similarities and what the
differences are.
And I'll think in terms of, in
fact, a quantization problem,
where I'm taking this
continuous-valued random
variable with density, and I'm
quantizing it into a set of
discrete points.
And I want to say what's the
difference between this
differential entropy here and
this discrete entropy, which
we sort of understand by now.
Well, things that are the same
-- the first thing that's the
same is the differential entropy
is still the expected
value of minus the logarithm
of the probability density.
OK, we found that that was
useful before when we were
trying to understand
the entropy.
It's the expected value
of a log pmf.
Now the differential entropy is
expected value of a log pdf
instead of pmf.
And the entropy of two random
variables, U1 and U2, if
they're independent, is just the
differential entropy of U1
plus the differential
entropy of U2.
How do I see that?
You just write it down.
You write down these
joint densities.
You write down this.
The logarithm of the joint
density for IID splits into a
product of densities.
A log of a product is
the sum of the logs.
It's the same as the
argument before.
In other words, it's not only
that this is the same as the
answer that we got before,
but the argument
is exactly the same.
And the other thing, the next
thing is if you shift this
density here.
If I have a density, which is
going along here and I shift
it over to here and have a
density over there, the
entropy is the same again.
Because this entropy is just
fundamentally not -- it
doesn't have to do with where
you happen to be.
It has to do with what these
probability densities are.
And you can stick that shift
into here, and if you're very
good at doing calculus, you can,
in fact, see that when
you put a shift in here, you
still get the same entropy.
I couldn't do that at this
point, but I'm sure that all
of you can.
And I can do it if
I spent enough
time thinking it through.
It would just take me longer
than most of you.
OK, so all of these things
are still true.
There a couple of
very disturbing
differences, though.
And the first difference
is that h of U
is not scale invariant.
And, in fact, if it were
scale invariant, it
would be totally useless.
The fact that it's not scale
invariant turns out to be very
important when you try
to understand it, OK?
In other words, if you stretch
this probability density by
some quantity a, then your
probability density, which
looks like this, shifts
like this.
It shifts down and
it shifts out.
So the log of the
pmf gets bigger.
The pmf itself is just
sort of spread out.
It does what you would
expect it to do, and
that works very nicely.
But the log of the pmf has this
extra term which comes in
here, which is a factor of a.
And it turns out you can just
factor that factor of a out,
and you wind up with the
differential entropy of a
scaled random variable U is
equal to the differential
entropy of the original U plus
log of a, which might be
minus log of a.
I'm not sure which it is.
I'll write down plus
or minus log of a.
It's one or the other.
I don't care at this point.
All I'm interested
in is that you
recognize that it's different.
An even more disturbing point
is this differential entropy
can be negative.
It can be negative
or positive.
It can do whatever
it wants to do.
And so we're left with a sort
of a peculiar thing.
But we say, well, all right,
that's the way it is.
The physicists had
to deal with that
for many, many years.
And the physicists, who think
about it all the time, deal
with it and say it's
not very important.
So we'll say, OK, we'll go along
with this unless asked:
What happens if we try to build
a uniform high-rate
scalar quantizer, which is
exactly what you would do for
implementation purposes
anyway.
So how does this work?
You pick a little tiny delta.
You have all these
regions here.
And by uniform, I mean you make
all the regions the same.
I mean, conceptually, this might
mean having accountably
infinite number of regions.
Let's not worry about that
for the time being.
And you have points in here,
which are the conditional
means of the regions.
Well, if I assume that delta is
small, then the probability
density of u is almost constant
within a region, if
it really is a density.
And I can define an average
value of f of u within each
region in the following way.
It's easier to see what it is
graphically if I have a
density here, which runs
along like this.
And within each region, I will
choose f-bar of u to be a
piecewise constant version of
this density, which might be
like that, OK?
Now that's just analytical
stuff to make
things come out right.
If you read the notes about how
to do this, you find out
that this quantity is important
analytically to
trace through what's going on.
I think for the level that we're
at now, it's fine to
just say, OK, this is the same
as this, if we make the
quantization very small.
I mean, at some point in this
argument, you want to go
through and say, OK, what do
I mean by approximate?
Is the approximation close?
How does the approximation
become better as I make delta
smaller, and all of
these questions.
But let's just now say, OK, this
is the same as that, and
I'd like to find out how well
this uniform high-rate scalar
quantizer does.
So my high-rate approximation
is that this average density
is the same as the true
density and for
all possible u.
So conditional on u and Rj,
this quantity is constant.
It's constant and equal to 1
over delta, and the actual
density is approximately
equal to 1 over delta.
What's that mean?
It means that the mean square
error in one of these
quantization regions is our
usual delta squared over 12,
which is the mean square error
of a uniform density in a
region from minus delta over
2 to plus delta over 2.
So that's the mean
square error.
You can't do anything
with that.
You're stuck with it.
The next question is
what is the entropy
as a quantizer output?
I'm sorry, I'm giving a typical
MIT lecture today,
which people have characterized
as a fire hose,
and it's because I want to get
done with this material today.
I think if you read the notes
afterwards, you've got a
pretty good picture of
what's going on.
We are not going to have
an enormous number
of problems on this.
It's not something we're
stressing so I want to get you
to have some idea of what
this is all about.
This slide is probably the most
important slide because
it tells you what this
differential
entropy really is.
OK, I'm going to look at the
probabilities of each of these
discrete points now. p sub j
is the probability that the
quantizer will get the
point a sub j.
In other words, it is the
probability of the
region R sub j.
And that's just the integral
of the probability density
over the j-th region.
Namely, it's the probability of
being in that j-th region.
p sub j is also equal to this
average value times delta.
OK, so I look at what
the entropy is of
the high-rate quantizer.
It's the sum of minus
pj log pj.
I translate that pj is
equal to this, so I
have a sum over j.
I have an integral minus a fU of
u, which is that, times log
And now I'll use this quantity
instead of this quantity.
f-bar of u times delta du.
OK, in other words, these
probabilities are scaled by
delta, which is what I was
telling you before.
That's the crucial thing here.
As you make delta smaller and
smaller, the probabilities of
the intervals go down
with delta.
OK, so I break this up
into two terms now.
I take out the log of delta,
which is integrated over fU.
I have this quantity left.
This quantity is approximately
equal to the density, and what
I wind up with is that the
actual entropy of the
quantized version is equal to
the differential entropy minus
the log of delta at high rate.
OK, that's the only way I know
to interpret differential
entropy that makes any sense,
OK, in other words, usually
when you think of integrals,
you think of them
in a Riemann sense.
You think of breaking up the
interval into lots of very
thin slices with delta, and then
you integrate things by
adding up things, and that
integral then is then a sum.
It's the same as this
kind of sum.
And the integral that you wind
up with when you're dealing
with a log of the pmf, you
get this extra delta
sticking in there, OK?
So this entropy is this phony
thing minus log of delta.
As I quantize more and
more finely, this
entropy keeps going up.
It goes up because when delta is
very, very small, minus log
delta is a large number.
So as delta gets smaller and
smaller, this entropy heads
off towards infinity.
And in fact, you would expect
that because if you take a
real number, which has a
distribution which is -- well,
anything just between minus 1
and plus 1, for example, and I
want to represent it very, very
well if it's uniformly
distributed there, the better
I try to represent it, the
more bits it takes.
That's what this is saying.
This thing is changing as I try
to represent things better
and better.
This quantity here is just some
funny thing that deals
with the shape of the
probability density and
nothing else.
It essentially has a scale
factor built into it because
the probability density has a
scale factor built into it.
A probability density is
probability per unit length.
And therefore, this kind of
entropy has to have that unit
length coming in here somehow,
and that's the
way it comes in.
That's the way it is.
So to summarize all of that, and
I'm sure you haven't quite
understood all of it, but if
you do efficient discrete
coding at the end of the whole
thing, the number of bits per
sample, namely, per number
coming into the quantizer that
you need, is H of V, OK?
With this uniform quantizer,
which produces an entropy of
the symbols H of V, then you
L-bar bits per symbol to
represent that.
That's the result that
we had before.
This quantity H of V depends
only on delta and h of U.
Namely, h of U is equal to
H of V plus log delta.
So, in other words,
analytically, the only thing
you have to worry about
is what is this
differential entropy?
You can't interpret what it is,
but you can calculate it.
And once you calculate it,
this tells you what this
entropy is for every
choice of delta so
long as delta is small.
It says that when you get to the
point where delta is small
and the probability density is
essentially constant over a
region, if I want to make delta
half as big as it was
before, then I'm going to wind
up with twice as many
quantization regions.
They're all going to
be only half as
probable as the ones before.
It's going to take me
one extra bit to
represent that, OK?
Namely, this one extra bit for
each of these old regions is
going to tell me whether I'm on
the right side or the left
side of that old quantization
region to talk about the new
quantization region.
So this all make sense, OK?
Namely, the only thing that's
happening as you make the
quantization finer and finer is
that you have these extra
bits coming in, which are sort
of telling you what the fine
structure is.
And little h of U already has
built into it the overall
shape of the thing.
OK, now I've added one thing
more here, which I haven't
talked about at all.
This uniform scalar quantizer
in fact becomes optimal as
delta become small.
And that's not obvious;
it's not intuitive.
There's an argument
in the text that
shows why that is true.
It uses a Lagrange multiplier
to do it.
I guess there's a certain
elegance to it.
I mean, after years of thinking
about it, I would
say, yeah, it's pretty likely
that it's true if I didn't
have the mathematics
to know it's true.
But, in fact, it's a very
interesting result.
It says that what you do with
classical a to z converters,
if you're going to have very
fine quantization, is, in
fact, the right thing to do.